dibuja un círculo y etiqueta el radio el
diámetro el centro y la circunferencia
así que vamos a hacer lo voy a suponer
que este de aquí es mi círculo no está
tan perfecto pero es un buen círculo
ahora voy a etiquetar el centro justo
aquí lo voy a denotar con la letra c c
de centro y recuerden que el centro es
aquel punto que tiene una propiedad muy
importante todos los puntos de la
circunferencia le quedan a la misma
distancia también otra forma de llamar
la circunferencia puede hacer aquel
lugar geométrico desde todos los puntos
que existan al centro y más aún esa
distancia de mi centro a cualquier punto
de mi circunferencia se llama radio y
como cada uno de mis puntos de mi
circunferencia x distan al centro
entonces este también es un radio y este
también toda la línea que vaya de mi
centro a cualquier punto de mi
circunferencia se va a llamar radio
y bueno ahora falta definir lo que es el
diámetro el diámetro es aquella línea
que pasa por el centro y que va de un
lado a otro de mi círculo o también
podremos decir que son dos radios juntos
que van de un lado a otro de mi círculo
vamos a dibujarlo tengo que cruzar mi
círculo de un extremo a otro y pasar por
el centro muy bien aquí está mi primer
diámetro entonces voy a escribir
diámetro y dese cuenta que yo puedo
dibujar un montón de diámetros y también
un montón de radios por ejemplo este es
otro diámetro y así me podría pasar todo
el vídeo dibujando diámetros y rayos por
lo que creo que es mejor que nos vayamos
a lo que nos falta por último vamos a
definir circunferencia circunferencia es
cada uno de los puntos de mi perímetro
de mi círculo es decir la línea que
rodea a mi círculo o dicho de otra
manera es el camino que sigue al viajar
alrededor del círculo entonces todo lo
que acabo de remarcar es la
circunferencia si uno
y ya está hemos terminado